Unsere Rufe sind in den letzten
Jahren lauter geworden. Die Rufe
von uns Frauen nach Rechten, Chancen
und Respekt.
Bewegungen wie #metoo haben
Millionen von uns auf die Straße
gebracht und aufgezeigt, dass Männer
und Frauen
immer noch ungleich behandelt werden.
Was die Welt braucht, sind sichtbare
Frauen. Mächtige Frauen,
so wie die deutsche
Verteidigungsministerin
Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer,
die eine Armee von rund 200 000
befehligt.
Der grösste Gender Gap, dem ich in
meinem
Berufsalltag begegne, ist die
Abwesenheit von Frauen, und es ist
die Tatsache, dass Frauen nach wie
vor deutlich schlechter bezahlt
sind als die männlichen Kollegen.
Frauen wie die Schwedin Erika
Lust, die eine der letzten
Männerdomänen aufmischt: die
Pornografie.
Wenn wir über Sex reden, dann gibt es
auch heute noch einen grossen
Unterschied zwischen Männern und
Frauen: Die so genannte
"Orgasmus-Kluft".
Und Frauen wie Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin,
die sich alleine gegen den Sexismus
der Schweizer Medienbranche stellt -
und gewinnt.
Wenn ich die Zeitung lese,
da sind Frauen noch immer
Dekoration und irgendwie
spielen vor allem in der Werbung
mit. Und das stört mich.
Diese Frauen spielen die Hauptrolle
in dieser Serie, weil sie aktiv dazu
beitragen, dass die Welt zu einem
gerechteren Ort wird.
So wie das viele von uns versuchen-
auch ich.
Mein Name ist Patrizia Laeri.
Ich bin Ökonomin, Unternehmerin und
Journalistin.
Unser Vorsorgesystem benachteiligt
Menschen, die weniger verdienen
oder Teilzeit arbeiten.
Und das sind vor allem Frauen.
Ich bin aber auch Mutter und kenne
die Belastung, die berufstätige
Frauen mit Kindern aushalten müssen.
Als Wirtschaftsjournalistin bin ich
oft die einzige Frau in einem Raum
voller männlicher Kollegen.
Und auch meine Interviewpartner sind
oft Männer. Sie allein erklären uns
die Welt, und darauf habe ich keine
Lust mehr.
In dieser Folge will ich
herausfinden, welche Rolle Medien
für die Gleichberechtigung der
Frauen spielen.
Ob sie Geschlechter-Klischees
zementieren oder diese
aufbrechen.
Und was Frauen tagtäglich in den
sozialen Medien erleben.
Die
Geschichten von Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin, Anne Wizorek
und Sigi Maurer liefern mögliche
Antworten. Und
um sie dreht sich dieser Film.
An einem verregneten Montagmorgen
bin ich mit Rosanna Grüter, der
Macherin dieses Films, unterwegs
in Zug.
Hier, in dieser kleinen Stadt in der
Zentralschweiz, lebt Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin.
Mit welchen Gefühlen triffst du dich
denn jetzt mit Jolanda?
Also als
Journalistin und als
Vertreterin der Zunft
schäme ich mich fast ein bisschen.
Es war für mich einer der grössten
Medienskandale, die ich erlebt habe
in meiner Laufbahn als Journalistin.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob so etwas
auch in einem anderen Land hätte
passieren können.
Das ist alles noch vor #metoo
passiert.
Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin - diesen
Namen kennen in der Deutschschweiz
die allermeisten Leute.
Seit 2014 verdienen
eidgenössische Medien richtig viel
Geld mit ihr.
war sie sogar die meist gegooglete
Frau der Schweiz.
Und
das kam so: Im Winter 2014
besuchte Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin als
frisch gewählte grüne Kantonsrätin
eine Feier der Zuger
Regierung. Dort geschah etwas, das
ihr Leben für immer verändern und
die Schweiz auf Jahre beschäftigen
sollte.
Jolanda erwachte am nächsten
Morgen mit Erinnerungslücken
und Unterleibsschmerzen.
Alles wurde komisch und
es wurde vernebelt.
Und ich hab die Leute nicht mehr
erkannt. Und dann nach 10 Minuten
weiss ich nichts mehr.
Und aufgewacht bin ich zu Hause,
morgens um acht.
Nach ihrer Untersuchung im
Krankenhaus gelangte diese
Information an die Medien.
Wie genau, ist bis heute nicht
geklärt, sagt Jolanda.
Ich glaube, ich hätte
diese Geschichte nicht mal meinen
Eltern erzählt.
Ich glaube, das wäre etwas gewesen,
das ich für mich gehalten hätte.
Das Verfahren gegen
zwei Verdächtige, unter anderem den
damaligen Zuger
SVP-Präsidenten Markus Hürlimann,
wurde eingestellt.
Für die Schweizer Öffentlichkeit
ist ohnehin klar: Die Schuldige
ist Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin.
Rund 3000 Artikel erscheinen
nach diesen Geschehnissen über sie.
In vielen davon wird gemutmasst,
dass Jolanda einen Seitensprung
vertuschen will.
2015 sieht sie
sich deswegen gezwungen, ihre
politische Karriere an den Nagel
zu hängen.
Erst 2017 wendet
sich das Blatt: Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin geht in die Offensive
und beginnt gegen verschiedene
Medienhäuser und Journalisten zu
prozessieren.
Ausserdem gründet sie den Verein
NetzCourage, mit dem sie sich gegen
Hass im Netz engagiert,
insbesondere gegen Sexismus.
Irgendwann ist einfach mal Schluss
mit diesen "Fertigmachereien" von
Frauen, welche nicht schweigen
möchten. Ich danke fürs Zuhören.
Sie wird so in der Schweiz zu einer
feministischen Ikone.
Ich möchte wissen, woher sie die
Kraft dazu nimmt, welchen Einfluss
#metoo auf ihre Geschichte hatte
und wie wir es in Zukunft als
Gesellschaft vermeiden, wieder die
gleichen Fehler zu machen.
Die schlimmsten Artikel, die über
sie geschrieben wurden, hat Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin gesammelt.
Bei sich zuhause Zug
gewährt sie mir einen Einblick in
ihren Ordner der Schande.
Wenn ich mir das so anschaue, also
auch die ganzen Artikel
und... Es sieht eigentlich
so aus, als würde sich eine ganze
Branche an einer
Frau
ergeilen. Wie hast du das empfunden?
Ja, genau
so. Für mich unverständlich, dass da
auch Frauen mitgemacht haben.
Aber es war ja so!
Aber die hatten irgendwie sonst ein
Problem, glaube ich.
Aber all diese Männer,
diese alten Männer, welche über mich
geschrieben haben und gemutmasst
haben, was da passiert
ist hinter dieser geschlossenen
Tür... Ich meine, es war einfach nur
ekelhaft.
240 Artikel hat das
Schweizer Medienhaus Ringier, das
auch die Boulevardzeitung Blick
herausgibt, alleine über ihren
Fall geschrieben.
Schon ziemlich schnell wurde ich
zur Täterin gemacht.
Natürlich allem voran von der
Boulevardpresse, vom Blick.
Sogar in der seriösen Presse, im
Tagesanzeiger, hiess es dann,
ich schade allen Frauen mit
meinem Verhalten.
Und das ist heavy.
Ich meine, was sollen diese
Schlagzeilen?
Das ist so widerlich.
"Ein Nümmerchen für 48'000
Franken". Das ist so krass
verharmlosend, das alles.
Hauptsache, man kann die
Aufmerksamkeit der Leser:innen
gewinnen und die Auflage steigern.
Da wurde so viel Geld verdient mit
dieser Art von
Schlagzeilen.
Wie kann etwas so entgleisen?
Es hat... die Kontrollinstanz
hat gefehlt.
Es hat niemand die Reissleine
gezogen.
Es hätte jemand, Menschen hier
in Zug, also irgendwie ich
Politiker:innen, welche Macht...
Regierungspräsidenten, die hätten
Stopp sagen können.
Stopp gesagt hat niemand von ihren
ehemaligen Kolleginnen und Kollegen
im Zuger Kantonsrat.
Im Gegenteil: Man misstraut
dir öffentlich, genauso wie dem
Verdächtigen Markus Hürlimann.
Es gab Politiker:innen
aus allen Parteien, sogar
von linken Parteien, von der SP
z.B., welche
da mitgemacht haben. Die haben sich
da vor
die Kamera gedrängt und
Rücktritte gefordert.
Anstatt einfach zu sagen:
Diese Geschichte gehört nicht in die
Medien.
Wie will man hier von Vertrauen und
Ehrlichkeit sprechen, wenn man das
immer im Hinterkopf hat, was hier
passiert ist.
Ich glaube, die meisten Menschen
wären so, dass man sich zurückziehen
würde und sagen würde, ok es ist
vorbei, es ist passiert, aber ich
ziehe
mich zurück. Aber sie gehen voll in
die Offensive - das verstehe ich
nicht.
Da haben wir Mühe, wenn solche
Menschen nachher mit Ausreden und
Widersprüchen in den Medien sich aus
der Verantwortung ziehen.
Was ja immer wieder hier auch
durchdringt, in allen diesen
Artikeln wird ja dann auch
der Vorwurf laut: Du
hast diese Aufmerksamkeit, dieses
Blitzlichtgewitter, dieses
Medien-Scheinwerferlicht auch
gesucht.
Ich hätte mir nichts mehr gewünscht,
als dass man mich in Ruhe gelassen
hätte.
Wir mussten die Kinder aus der
Schule nehmen.
Ich musste
Antidepressiva nehmen, obwohl ich
stets ein sehr fröhlicher Mensch
war, da kam
ich nicht drumherum. Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich sonst noch leben würde.
Ich denke, die Pharmabranche hat
mir da recht viel gerettet.
Noch viel wichtiger ist zu dieser
Zeit aber die Unterstützung ihres
Ehemanns. Reto
Spiess stand immer bedingungslos auf
der Seite seiner Frau und tut
das bis heute.
Er äussert sich nicht gern vor den
Medien, macht vor uns aber eine
Ausnahme.
Bei einem Kaffee in ihrer
gemeinsamen Wohnung erzählt er mir,
warum er Journalist:innen gegenüber
normalerweise misstrauisch ist.
Die Journalisten, die mich
kontaktiert haben, das waren dann
eigentlich die Bösen. Jene, die
jetzt verurteilt sind oder
sich in Strafverfahren
befinden.
Die haben dann mich beispielsweise
bei der Arbeit angerufen
und mich um eine
Stellungnahme gebeten.
Das haben sie natürlich mit
viel Charme, so gut es möglich
war, versucht und
mich zuerst freundlich versucht zu
ködern. Und als ich da
abgelehnt habe, haben sie mir Druck
gemacht. Und
die letzte Druckstufe war dann
zu sagen: Wenn sie nichts sagen,
dann schreiben wir halt irgendeinen
Bocksmist.
Und so ist es dann auch gekommen.
So stand dann in der Weltwoche, ich
sei ausgezogen aus der gemeinsamen
Wohnung...
...und hättest die Kinder gerade noch
mitgenommen, ja.
Es ist ja sehr schwer vorstellbar,
wenn so eine Lawine
hereinbricht.
Wie funktioniert man da als Familie
weiter?
Ja, und man verliert schon
auch ein Stück weit das
Urvertrauen, das man vielleicht
vorher hatte.
Und wenn man merkt,
wie man einfach ins Bodenlose
stürzt,
wo sich Dinge ereignen, die man sich
in den schlimmsten Träumen nicht
hätte vorstellen können.
Das zerstört schon etwas im Innern.
Wir mussten übrigens auch die
Fenster
abdecken, aus Angst
vor Journalist:innen.
Die Polizei patrouillierte im
Quartier.
Und als ich das so ein bisschen, ja,
die Medienkampagne
hat Fahrt aufgenommen,
da haben wir uns entschieden, auf
ärztlichen Rat hin, dass wir
die Gegend für eine Zeit verlassen.
Ja, das war die Katastrophe.
Ich hatte da wirklich einen
Zusammenbruch erlebt am
Tag nach Heiligabend.
Und ja, da musste
ich dann medizinische Hilfe
in Anspruch nehmen.
Da bin ich aber der Meinung, da ist
dann Jolanda eigentlich sehr schnell
wieder auf die Beine gekommen und
hat sehr schnell in den
Kämpfermodus geschaltet.
Und
ja, sich aufgerappelt und
auch den Rest der Familie da
mitgezogen.
Wann kam dann schliesslich der
Wendepunkt?
Ich glaub für die öffentliche
Wahrnehmung
war es
das Interview von Reto mit Watson.
2017 redet Reto Spiess,
abgesehen von heute, das erste
und einzige Mal öffentlich über
seine Frau.
Diese ist davon überzeugt: Das
Interview hat zu einem Umdenken über
Ihren Fall geführt.
Wie kam es zu diesem
Schlüssel-Interview?
Eben. Es war mir eigentlich von
Anfang an klar, dass der Moment
kommen wird, wo
ich in die Offensive gehen muss
und auch will.
Und
das Schwierige war, den richtigen
Moment abzuwarten, die richtige
Person, den richtigen Journalisten
abzuwarten und
es dann zu platzieren, um nicht
in Hektik zu verfallen.
Und nach zweieinhalb Jahren
war Hansi Voigt dieser Mann,
der keine
fixe Vorstellung hatte, was genau
passiert ist.
Er war offen.
Er konnte mit diesem Interview
und auch akribischer Recherchearbeit
eine Gegendarstellung machen.
Der Mann, der das Interview mit Reto
Spiess damals geführt hat,
heisst Hansi Voigt.
Er war drei Jahre lang Chefredakteur
beim Schweizer Online-Medium Watson
und ist einer der wenigen
Journalisten, der bereits 2017
auch Jolandas Seite beleuchtet
hat.
Ich besuche ihn zuhause in Sargans
und
spreche mit ihm über die Rolle, die
Watson und er in Jolandas Geschichte
spielen.
Was hat denn dieses Interview mit
dem Ehemann von Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin verändert?
Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin, die wurde ja
irgendwie
manipuliert oder irgendwie
abgeklemmt.
Oder, wenn sie irgendetwas versucht
hat, wurde das eher negativ
dargestellt.
Und ich hab dann ihr
gesagt, ich würde gerne mit ihrem
Mann reden.
Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, aha,
da kommt der Mann und der redet
wieder nur mit dem Mann und so
weiter. Und erst dann gilt es.
Es ist wahrscheinlich verblüffend,
wie viel mehr Wirkung diese
Geschichte erzielt hat, weil
der Mann spricht.
Auffällig bei diesem Interview ist
ja auch, da sind sehr sexistische
Fragen dabei.
Ich finde es total wichtig, diese
Fragen, die ich mir nie stellen
würde, nach der Kürze des Rocks oder
schulterfreien Kleidern oder sowas.
Das waren aber die Fragen, die die
Leute in den Köpfen hatten.
Ich musste die stellen. Und unter
anderem mit der sehr unangenehmen
Frage,
ob er nicht manchmal das Gefühl hat,
sie solle doch endlich Ruhe geben.
Dann hat er gesagt, das finde ich
bis heute absolut großartig: Jolanda
kämpft auf ihre Weise.
Ich kämpfe eher auf die ruhige
Weise, aber wir machen beide einfach
so lang, bis es gerecht
ist.
Und das ist mal ein Statement.
Hat dieser Artikel in der
Medienszene dann zu einem Umdenken
geführt?
Teils, teils.
Ich meine, das ist ein Spiegel, den
man der Medienszene vorhält.
Und manche
fanden diesen Spiegel nicht sehr
angenehm.
Aber andere haben tatsächlich
angefangen zu sagen: hey,
tatsächlich, da gibt's eine andere
Version als was wir uns
da in unserem Kopfkino irgendwie
alles dazumal ausgereimt
haben.
Wir sind von einer falschen Annahme
ausgegangen. Und so haben sich
verschiedene Journalisten auch
öffentlich entschuldigt.
Dazu gehören z.B.
Erich Aschwanden von der Neuen
Zürcher Zeitung...
Ich
würde den Artikel so nicht mehr
schreiben. Eigentlich hätte man
schauen
müssen, ok, was ist Fakt? Und dann
basierend darauf, seine Artikel
schreiben müssen.
... oder Carmen Epp von der Online
News-Plattform Zentralplus.
Wenn ich damals gewusst hätte, wie
wichtig es ist, dass sich
Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin gegen die
Vorwürfe, welche in den Medien
kursierten, wehrt,
hätte ich diese Artikel nicht
geschrieben.
Was hat diese Geschichte für
Mechanismen bedient?
Diese Geschichte hat natürlich
alles, was im klassischen Boulevard,
den es vielleicht nochmal zu
definieren gilt, wirklich eine
Rolle spielt, was als
erfolgsversprechend gelten würde.
Also diese ganze Formel "Titten,
Tränen, Tiere" also quasi
als dieser ganze Appell an die
Emotionalität des Lesers,
ist hier natürlich enorm
vorhanden.
Aber nennen wir vielleicht auch das
Kind beim Namen: Mit solchen
Geschichten kann man natürlich sehr
viel Geld verdienen.
Wieviel?
Da macht man vielleicht 300'000
Franken im Online-Umsatz und dann
vielleicht nochmal 600'000, 700'000
im Print als Umsatz.
Also da ist man relativ schnell bei
einer runden Million Bruttogewinn,
der erzielt wurde allein mit der
Berichterstattung über Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin.
Mich stimmt betroffen, wie viel
Medien damit verdient haben, Jolanda
öffentlich zu vernichten.
Gleichzeitig bin ich froh darüber,
dass sich der Ton der
Berichterstattung über sie doch noch
gewandelt hat.
Das Interview mit Reto Spiess
hat dabei sicher eine Rolle
gespielt.
Noch viel wichtiger dürfte aber ein
anderes Ereignis gewesen sein.
Im Oktober 2017
erschüttert #metoo die Welt.
Die Schauspielerin Alyssa Milano
macht den Hashtag populär,
unter dem später Hunderttausende
von Frauen ihre Erfahrungen mit
sexueller Gewalt in den Sozialen
Medien teilen werden.
Ausgelöst wird diese Lawine durch
den Skandal um den Hollywood
Produzenten Harvey Weinstein,
der von Dutzenden von Frauen
beschuldigt wurde, sie sexuell
belästigt zu haben.
Darunter so berühmte
Schauspielerinnen wie Gwyneth
Paltrow und Angelina Jolie.
#metoo löst endlich eine längst
fällige öffentliche Debatte
über sexuelle Gewalt aus.
Und auch privat sprechen wir Frauen
öfters über dieses Thema.
Mit Filmemacherin und
Freundin Rosanna tausche ich mich
z.B. regelmäßig darüber aus,
wie #metoo die Medienbranche
verändert hat - und unser eigenes
Leben.
Ich habe gemerkt, dass ich sehr,
sehr viel verdrängt habe, vor allem
auch als Praktikantin.
Was man da alles erlebt an
Machtmissbrauch, auch latente
Ausnutzung der höheren
Positionen, was man im Arbeitsleben
und gerade auch im Mediensektor
alles erlebt.
Was mir auch aufgefallen ist, dass
man früher auch wirklich ganz
viel erduldet hat.
Man hat weggesehen.
Man hat oft auch den Journalisten
oder Männern die
Praktikantinnen-Betreuung übergeben,
die eben sehr
anzügliche Sachen gesagt
haben, gemacht haben.
Da erinnere ich mich auch dran.
Warum glaubst du, ist das so?
Das frag ich mich einfach ständig,
immer wieder.
Wieso hat es so lange gedauert,
bis irgendwie
dieser Aufschrei kam?
Also, dass man halt
eigentlich vieles lernt
sich selber zuzuschreiben, sich
selbstkritisch zu sehen,
die Schuld eher bei sich zu suchen.
Ich meine, ich bin aufgewachsen mit
einer Mutter, die das sehr
konservativ gesehen hat,
die auch gesagt hat, jetzt gehst
du ins Gymnasium, in eine
Stadt und da ziehst du sicher keine
kurzen Röcke an.
Sonst passiert dir was.
Die Verantwortung liegt ja auch bei
den Frauen. Wenn du nicht möchtest,
dass dir etwas passiert, dann sollst
du dein Verhalten anpassen.
Das wird dir als Frau beigebracht.
Ich habe das nie irgendwie erlebt,
dass meinem Bruder gesagt worden
wäre: Hey, egal
wie eine Frau gekleidet ist, das
darfst du nicht tun.
Das ist irgendwie nie passiert, in
meiner Erinnerung, in meiner
Kindheit.
Und die Welt ist einfach so.
Man hat das akzeptiert.
Die Mechanismen sind so
und man hat sich das auch
schöngeredet als Frau oft.
Der ist halt so charmant, alte
Schule.
Das macht man halt noch so.
Glaubst du, #metoo hat den
Frauen einen Vorteil gebracht
letztlich?
Es hat unter den Frauen eine
Solidarisierung mit sich gebracht.
Ich finde, die Scham, die irgendwie
mit solchen Geschichten einhergeht,
ist kleiner geworden.
Also bist du auch mutiger und
selbstbewusster geworden dadurch?
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Eine der Frauen, die dafür
verantwortlich ist, dass die
Diskussion über sexuelle Gewalt
überhaupt ins Rollen kam, ist die
Deutsche Aktivistin Anne Wizorek.
Sie organisierte z.B.
die Berliner "Slutwalks2,
an denen Tausende von Frauen für
ihre sexuelle Selbstbestimmung
demonstrierten.
Und sie lancierte den Hashtag
#aufschrei auf Twitter, quasi
der deutsche Vorläufer von #metoo.
2013 wurde sie
dafür mit dem Grimme Online Award
ausgezeichnet, einem
renommierten deutschen Medienpreis.
Hallo! Das waren wir!
Das ist Patrizia.
Sie wird das Interview mit dir
führen.
Freut mich sehr, dich
virtuell mal kennenzulernen.
Was stecken für Erfahrungen hinter
dem Hashtag, auch bei dir
persönlich?
Also ich habe längst nicht alles
geteilt, was ich an Erfahrungen
selber schon machen musste, aber
habe unter anderem darüber
geschrieben, wie ich eben
als Studentin
von dem Professor, bei dem ich
in einer Sprechstunde war,
anzügliche Fragen gestellt bekommen
hatte, wo ich dann
auch später herausbekommen habe,
dass er sozusagen schon bekannt
dafür ist, auch gerne
sich ja junge
gutaussehende Studentinnen irgendwie
dann als Hilfskräfte zu organisieren
und dergleichen.
Ansonsten hat sich unter dem Hashtag
die ganze Bandbreite von
Sexismus und sexualisierter Gewalt
gezeigt. Also von
Bemerkungen in der Schule, wie
wenn der Lehrer dann sagt, die
Mädchen
können ja eh keine Mathe, bis
hin zu
man wird beim Ausgehen irgendwie
begrapscht, nachts verfolgt.
Aber auch sexuelle
Übergriffe innerhalb der Familie
z.B. wurden geschildert.
Du kämpfst ja an verschiedenen
Fronten quasi, du hast sehr viele
Initiativen, Projekte.
Z.B..
Da war diese "Netz ohne Gewalt"
Aktion mit sehr vielen Expert:innen
und Politiker:innen auch.
Um was ging es dabei?
Mir war das wichtig, da Menschen
zusammenzubringen, die zum Thema
digitale Gewalt zusammenarbeiten,
aber auch vor allem nicht aus
dem Blick verlieren, dass da auch
geschlechtsspezifische Gewalt
nochmal eine große Rolle spielt.
Also wir möchten damit einfach auch
ein Statement setzen, dass digitale
Gewalt noch viel größer ist als
dieses, sag ich jetzt mal, was
unter diesem Begriff, "Hass im Netz"
mitunter kursiert.
Also die häusliche Gewalt
oder auch die Gewalt nach einer
Trennung in einer Beziehung
wird immer häufiger auch mit Hilfe
von digitalen Medien ausgeübt.
Da werden dann Tracking Devices
benutzt. Da werden vielleicht
Bilder, die zuerst im Einverständnis
geteilt wurden miteinander,
vielleicht auch Nacktbilder, dann
dem entsprechend unerlaubt
verbreitet. Also auch das ist
digitale Gewalt und dieses
Feld ist einfach sehr viel größer
als sozusagen "nur" die
Hasskommentare, die wir gerade sehr
stark im Fokus haben.
Und weshalb ist
dieser Kampf gegen Hass im Netz,
gegen digitale Gewalt
eine gesellschaftliche Aufgabe?
Es ist ja so: Das Internet
kann ja nur so gut sein wie die
Menschen, die es benutzen.
Und wenn es missbraucht wird, um
Menschen wiederum zu stalken,
zu bedrohen,
ihnen ja auch wirklich ein
psychisches und am Ende damit auch
körperliches Leid zuzufügen,
dann ist das etwas, was wir ganz
klar adressieren müssen.
In der Schweiz kämpft Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin gegen Hass
im Netz.
Wie siehst du ihre Geschichte?
Sie leistet da wirklich gerade
Pionierinnen-Arbeit, finde ich.
Also gerade, was die ganze
Diskussion rund um digitale Gewalt
angeht, aber natürlich auch Umgang
mit Medien, mit Frauen
und wie Sexismus in der Branche
sich auch nochmal auswirkt und
was das für die Berichterstattung
gerade auch zu sexualisierter Gewalt
dann nochmals heisst.
Und da
kann ich nur hoffen, dass das genug
Menschen auch wertschätzen, was sie
da sie da gerade macht.
2017 ist das Wendejahr
für Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin. Danach
geht sie in die Offensive und
beginnt gegen sexistische
Berichterstattung und den Hass,
der ihr in den Sozialen Medien
entgegenschlägt, zu kämpfen.
Sie verklagt unter anderem das
Medienhaus Ringier, das die
Zeitung Blick herausgibt.
Ihr Name hätte in der allerersten
Schlagzeile über ihren Fall 2014
nicht genannt werden dürfen.
Wie wichtig war es dir, juristisch
vorzugehen?
Absolut wichtig.
Ich glaube, die Stärke, die ich
jetzt in mir trage, die
habe ich gewonnen durch diese
wichtigen juristischen Siege.
Es gab eine Zeit, da glaubte ich
nicht mehr an den Rechtsstaat.
Und dies wieder zu
spüren, dass das System
funktioniert.
Das war für mich was vom
Wichtigsten. Der absolut wichtigste
Sieg war bis jetzt natürlich schon
dieser gegen Ringier.
Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin erringt
gegen den Blick einen Teilsieg.
Die Zeitung habe mit ihrer
Berichterstattung die
Persönlichkeitsrechte der ehemaligen
Zuger Kantonsrätin widerrechtlich
verletzt.
Die Geschichte von Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin wühlt vieles in mir
auf.
Und wenn ich aufgewühlt bin, dann
male ich.
Dunkle, gejagte Bilder.
Denn auch ich habe bereits
Erfahrungen mit sexistischer
Berichterstattung machen müssen.
Wie das damals war, erzähle ich
Rosanna.
Ja, ich hab halt gemerkt, das ging
in den Köpfen wie nicht zusammen.
Da kommt eine junge, attraktive Frau
und die erzählt uns was über
Wirtschaft.
Und da hab ich schon von Anfang an
in meiner Karriere immer Kommentare
und Briefe erhalten: "Was
will mir diese Barbie von Wirtschaft
und Börsenkursen erzählen?
Was macht die da?
Die versteht ja nichts." Ich bin
Ökonomin und habe mir das hart
erarbeitet und auch härter
erarbeitet, als männliche Kollegen
oder andere Moderatoren, die haben
gar nicht Wirtschaft studiert.
Die hatten halt graue Haare und
diesen Senior-Look, der
ihnen anscheinend Kompetenz
verliehen hat, mehr als eigentlich
ein Studium zum Fachgebiet.
Und das hat mich schon seit
jeher verfolgt.
Leider auch die Presse hat das
auch immer so gesehen.
Es ging immer nur um
den Jugendwahn, den Schönheitswahn
des SRF.
Wie lange ist das denn her?
Es ist noch nicht lange her, das ist
drei Jahre her...
Da warst du ja nicht 16...
Nein,
ich war 40. Aber klar,
das ist ein Jugendwahn.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen hat ein
Problem mit Jugendwahn.
Aber da hab ich entschieden, dass
ich mich wehren möchte.
Ich habe eine Anwältin angerufen
und gesagt, so gehe es nicht.
Und die hat natürlich klar gesagt,
die müssen sich entschuldigen, die
müssen das korrigieren.
Da gehen wir jetzt dagegen
vor und verlangen das alles.
Da folgte dann auch wirklich eine
Berichtigung mit den richtigen
Berufsbezeichnungen und dem
Hintergrund und den Kompetenzen und
auch eine Entschuldigung.
Die Anwältin, die mir damals
geholfen hat, ist Rena Zulauf.
Sie ist DIE Schweizer
Medienrechtsanwältin und vertritt
auch Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin vor
Gericht.
Ich besuche Sie
in Ihrer Kanzlei in Zürich und
möchte von ihr wissen, welche
weiteren Verfahren Sie und Jolanda
gegen Ringier anstreben.
Im zweiten Verfahren, das wir jetzt
angestrengt haben, geht es darum,
dass der Gewinn, den Ringier
AG erwirtschaftet
hat, Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin
zugesprochen wird.
Je mehr Klicks ein Beitrag
generiert, desto mehr Werbung können
Sie um diesen Beitrag platzieren,
desto mehr Gewinn kann ein
Medienunternehmen generieren.
Und das hat eine fatale Folge,
weil insbesondere
Medienbeiträge klicken,
die Schockierendes, Skandalisieren
oder Abstruses bringen.
Bei Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin war es
beispielsweise so, dass einer der
meist geklickten Beiträge, dort hiess
es:
"Was geschah hinter dieser Tür?"
Und man konnte auf diese Tür klicken
und diese Versuchung, hier zu
klicken und zu sehen, was geschieht
jetzt dahinter?
Sind jetzt da zwei gerade mitten im
Akt?
Das löst einen Reflex aus
bei vielen Menschen und sie klicken
auf diesen Artikel.
Das heisst, mit
wenig journalistischem
Aufwand können Sie heute
unglaublich erfolgreiche Artikel
lancieren.
Wir haben im Recht bislang
sehr wenig Rechtsprechung zum Thema
Gewinnherausgabe.
Deswegen sind wir hier
wohl derjenige Fall,
der mutmaßlich wegweisend
werden könnte.
Hat es Sie erstaunt?
So ein erfahrenes Medienunternehmen
wie Ringier, dass das jetzt so weit
ging in der Berichterstattung?
Es hat mich leider Gottes nicht
erstaunt.
Ich glaube, das war ganz einfach
Kalkül.
Jolanda Spiess-Heggin hat gut
geklickt.
Also ich glaube beim Blick
gehört dieses Risiko,
das einkalkuliert wird,
letztlich bedauerlicherweise
zum Geschäftsmodell.
Ringier hat sich zwar öffentlich bei
Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin entschuldigt,
das
Geschäftsmodell könnte aber so
oder so bald veraltet sein.
Wenn sie auch ihren nächsten Prozess
gegen Ringier gewinnt, muss ihr
das Medienhaus den Gewinn
ausbezahlen, den es mit ihr gemacht
hat. Und wenn das passiert, haben
Medienunternehmen in der Schweiz in
Zukunft keinen Anreiz mehr,
mit solchen Geschichten Geld zu
verdienen.
Das könnte die Medienbranche in der
Schweiz dramatisch verändern.
Das reicht aber längst nicht, findet
Jolanda. Denn sie hat auch
in den Sozialen Medien viel Hass
erfahren müssen.
Wir Frauen wissen: wenn wir uns
wehren, schlägt uns oft grosse Wut
entgegen.
Du hast ja sehr viel erlebt
in punkto Hass.
Gibt es dennoch Botschaften, die
dich selber immer noch erschüttern?
Also wirklich
mitgenommen hat mich diese
Nachricht.
Da wünscht mir jemand den Tod, ganz
klar, aber auch meinen Kindern.
Und der beschreibt hier ganz
detailliert, was er mit den Kindern
machen wird, bevor sie dann sterben.
Ein Mensch hat sowas geschrieben und
findet, das ist so.
Das
macht mir natürlich Angst, das ist
anonym. Es kann jeder sein.
Es kann irgendwie
mein Nachbar sein, theoretisch.
Es gibt auch Nachrichten, die nehmen
Bezug auf mich,
auf meine Kleider, die ich an einem
Tag trage.
Beschreiben dann, wie
ich ausgesehen habe, welche Farbe
mein T-Shirt hatte und so.
Es war aber so, dass das ein
anonymer Facebook-Account war.
Der wurde eigens erstellt, um diese
Drohungen mir zu schicken
und die Staatsanwaltschaft konnte
nichts machen. Die haben zwar ein
Rechtshilfegesuch gestellt, aber
ich glaube gar keine Antwort
bekommen von Facebook.
Und das ist eigentlich das
Tragische.
Man ist wirklich sehr, sehr
ausgeliefert.
Diese Konzerne machen, was sie
wollen.
Sie verdienen so viel Geld,
aber müssen sich nicht an die
Schweizer Gesetze halten.
In Österreich ist dies nun anders.
Dort wurde im Dezember 2020
ein Gesetzespaket gegen Hass im
Netz verabschiedet.
Dieses macht es einerseits für die
Opfer leichter, sich zu wehren.
Andererseits nimmt es auch
Kommunikationsplattformen wie
Facebook und Co.
in die Pflicht.
Treibende Kraft hinter dem Gesetz
war die Grüne Politikerin und
Nationalrätin Sigi Maurer.
Sie treffe ich an ihrem Arbeitsort
bei den Grünen in Wien und lasse
mir das Gesetzespaket noch einmal
im Detail erklären.
Also es sind zwei verschiedene
Gesetzesteile. Das eine ist das
Kommunikationsplattformengesetz, da
geht es darum, dass Facebook,
Twitter und Co. in die Pflicht
genommen werden, dass sie
Ansprechpartner haben im Land, dass
direkt geklagt werden kann, wenn man
etwas zum Klagen hat, dass
Meldesysteme eingerichtet werden
müssen und auch, dass Postings
gelöscht werden müssen.
Und das zweite ist, dass
im Zivilrecht Möglichkeiten
geschaffen wurden, dass tatsächlich
leichter geklagt werden kann.
Habt ihr jetzt durch das eines
der strengsten Gesetze
europaweit gegen Hassrede?
Wir haben jedenfalls ein
Gesetzespaket, das auf beiden
Seiten, also auf Seiten der
Kommunikationsplattformen als auch
auf Seiten der Betroffenen, wo wir
die betroffenen Rechte und den
Schutz der Betroffenen massiv
ausgebaut haben, da haben wir sicher
das beste Gesetz, würde ich sagen,
ja.
Also wenn ich mir solche
Gruppierungen anschaue und man
sieht, dass eben wirklich auch
Online-Gewalt plötzlich auch in
Offline-Gewalt überschwappen kann,
dann frage ich mich schon - und
ich versteh's bis heute noch nicht -
woher kommt diese tiefe Wut
gegenüber Frauen?
Na ja, das ist ja auch nichts Neues.
Also vieles, was
ich auf Facebook über
Nachrichten bekomme,
wird am Stammtisch genauso
ausgesprochen.
Also ich komme ursprünglich aus
Tirol, aus so einem
Tal mit sehr viel Ski-Tourismus und
was dort in den Discos herumgebrüllt
wird, das ist unerträglich und
das ist kein neues Phänomen.
Also der Hass entsteht ja nicht,
weil es das Netz gibt, sondern der
Hass ist schon da.
Was, glaube ich, schon dazu kommt,
ist dass die Gesellschaft
sich insgesamt verändert.
Frauen werden nicht mehr
so eindeutig auf einen Platz
geschoben. Sie wehren sich,
sie sind laut.
Sie haben plötzlich ähnliche
Privilegien wie die Männer.
Und das ist natürlich Machtverlust.
Und damit tun sich viele
Männer schwer, dass sie sich jetzt
nicht mehr, nur weil sie Männer
sind, schon eine
bessere Stellung in der Gesellschaft
sichern können.
Das ist offensichtlich für viele
bedrohlich.
Sigi Maurers politisches Engagement
gegen Hass im Netz basiert
auf eigenen Erfahrungen.
2018 erhielt sie vom
Facebook-Account eines
Wiener Bierlokals eine obszöne
Nachricht, oder klarer: eine
Vergewaltigungs-Drohung, kurz
nachdem sie an ebendiesem Lokal
vorbeigegangen war.
Sie veröffentlichte die Nachricht
mitsamt dem Namen des Ladenbesitzers
auf Facebook.
Er zeigte sie infolgedessen wegen
übler Nachrede und Kreditschädigung
an.
Erstinstanzlich wurde Sigi Maurer
schuldig gesprochen und zu einem
Bußgeld von insgesamt 7000
Euro verurteilt.
Der Richter glaubte ihr zwar,
allerdings habe sie nicht beweisen
können, dass tatsächlich der
Ladenbesitzer die Nachricht
geschrieben habe.
Zweitinstanzlich wurde das Urteil
dann zwar aufgehoben, der Schock
sitzt bei Sigi Maurer aber immer
noch tief.
Sie nimmt mich mit zum Landesgericht
für Strafsachen in Wien, an
den Ort, an dem sie verurteilt
wurde, weil sie sich gewehrt hatte.
Sigi wie viele Male hast du diesen
Weg gemacht?
Ja, ich glaube drei, vier, fünfmal,
fünfmal.
Hier wurdest du erstinstanzlich
verurteilt.
Was hast du in dem Moment gedacht?
Ich bin am zweiten Prozesstag
dann schuldig gesprochen worden.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, das gibt's
doch wohl nicht, habe mir aber auch
gedacht: gut, dann gehe ich halt bis
zum Europäischen Gerichtshof, wenn
es sein muss. Und ja, es
hat sich gezogen über zweieinhalb
Jahre.
Es waren mehrere 10'000 Euro,
die dieser Prozess gekostet hat.
Es ist jetzt so, dass der Kläger
eigentlich die Kosten übernehmen
muss. Ich gehe leider davon aus,
dass er es nicht zahlen kann.
Bis jetzt hast du alles selber
gezahlt?
Selbstverständlich.
Wenn du jetzt
zurückdenkst, hat sich das gelohnt?
Also gelohnt.
Ich habe mir ja nicht ausgesucht,
dass ich verklagt werde dafür, dass
ich mich gegen Hass im Netz wehre.
Aber ich würde sagen, in der
Gesamtheit der Geschichte
ist es gut ausgegangen.
Es hat zwar sehr viel Geld gekostet,
aber wir haben ein
großes Gesetzespaket gegen Hass
im Netz auf den Weg bringen können.
Und es gibt einen Rechtshilfe-Fonds
für andere Betroffene von Hass im
Netz, mit dem sie unterstützt
werden, wenn sie klagen möchten.
Und ich glaube, insgesamt ist die
Awareness für das Thema einfach sehr
gestiegen und auch die Akzeptanz
von Hass im Netz deutlich gesunken.
Im Fall von Sigi Maurer ist aus
einem schlimmen Erlebnis eine neue
Gesetzgebung
gegen Hass im Netz entstanden. Ende
gut, alles gut, könnte
man meinen.
Nur: In Deutschland und in der
Schweiz sieht es ganz anders
aus als in Österreich.
Hier hinken die Gesetze noch immer
stark hinter dem realen Leben
im digitalen Zeitalter her.
Und genau hier setzt Jolanda
Spiess-Hegglin mit ihrem Projekt
"NetzCourage" an.
Seit 2016 kämpft sie mit
dem Verein gegen Hass im Netz,
insbesondere gegen Sexismus,
aber auch gegen alle anderen Formen
von Diskriminierung.
Sie leistet Soforthilfe für die
Opfer und betreibt Aufklärungs- und
Präventionsarbeit.
Bereits mehrfach wurde sie für ihre
Arbeit ausgezeichnet, auch in
Deutschland.
Warum sind Frauen so viel mehr
betroffen als Männer?
Ich glaube,
in den Augen vieler Männer sind
Frauen halt wirklich noch
nicht auf der gleichen Ebene.
Viele meiner Hater haben, glaube
ich, nicht verstanden, dass
Frauen dieselben Rechte haben,
dass sie die Gleichstellung
eigentlich leben sollten.
Also viele dieser
Hater, die nutzen die Sozialen
Medien halt auch, um diesen Hass
auszuleben, weil sie das vielleicht
zu Hause nicht mehr können.
Also weil sie da in die Schranken
gewiesen werden. Oder im Restaurant,
am Stammtisch z.B.
wird es nicht mehr so goutiert.
Aber online auf
den Sozialen Medien, da
hat es keine Barriere.
Ich mache von allem - und das hab
ich mir angewöhnt -
Screenshots. Sofort, bevor ich
irgendetwas anderes mache, mache ich
immer einen Screenshot, der
wird sofort gespeichert
auf einem externen Server.
Zwischen
50 und auch
80 Tausend Screenshots, glaube ich,
sind da schon drauf.
Ein Archiv des Hasses.
Ja, es ist wahrscheinlich die größte
Hass -Datenbank der Schweiz,  glaube
ich.
Gibt's auch bekannte, prominente
Frauen, die sich bei dir melden?
Ja, das gibts.
Ich stehe nicht unter
Schweigepflicht, glaube ich.
Aber ich hausiere auch nicht mit
Namen. Aber ich habe auch schon
eine Bundesrätin beraten.
Das gibt es.
Es sind wirklich nicht
einfach linke Frauen.
Es sind bürgerliche
Frauen und auch bürgerliche Männer,
es
sind CEO's und es sind auch
Migranten.
Einfach alle. Ich glaube, Hass im
Netz trifft uns einfach alle.
Kannst du mir auch ein Beispiel
geben von einem ganz bekannten
Fall?
Also ein Fall, welcher sehr
großes Aufsehen erregt hat - in der
Presse auch - das war, als ein paar
Juso-Frauen BH's verbrannt haben. Es
war ein feministisches Symbol und es
hat wahnsinnig viele alte Männer
getriggert.
Gemeinsam mit der damaligen
Präsidentin der Schweizer
Jungsozialisten, Tamara Funiciello,
erstattete Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin
rund 40 Mal Anzeige.
Daraufhin wurden über 20 Männer
verurteilt.
Und das gab dann so einen kleinen
Aufschrei im Sinne von:
"oh, passt auf!
Wir werden beobachtet.
Wir werden angezeigt.
Wir dürfen uns jetzt nicht mehr
alles leisten, was wir früher noch
täglich gemacht haben!"
Ja, ich glaube, da müssen wir auch
ein bisschen mehr noch hinschauen.
Ich glaube, auch die Politik hat das
noch nicht ganz verstanden, was
Soziale Medien halt auch für
eine Kraft haben.
Nicht nur die Kraft der Sozialen
Medien ist groß, sondern
auch jene von Jolanda Spiess-
Hegglin.
Wie sie es geschafft hat, sich wie
ein Phönix aus der Asche aus den
Trümmern ihres Lebens zu erheben,
das möchte ich wissen.
Und: Woher nimmt sie die Kraft,
sich jeden Tag mit so viel
Hass zu beschäftigen?
Ich finde, eine Geschichte,
wie ich sie erlebt habe, darf sich
nicht wiederholen. Es darf nie mehr
sowas passieren.
Ich will, dass meine Tochter sowas
nicht erlebt, und auch ihre
Freundinnen nicht. Und
deswegen braucht es eine
Aufarbeitung der Geschehnisse.
Eine Ungerechtigkeit löst
soviel aus und lässt
einem eigentlich Flügel
wachsen. Und irgendwann kann man
fliegen,
schafft man Dinge, die man
nie schaffen würde, wenn
das nicht so schlimm gewesen
wäre.
Wenn wir einmal alles hinter uns
haben, wenn dann auch die Kinder
nicht mehr hier in der Schule sind,
wenn wir wieder etwas freier sind,
dann gehen wir dann weg.
Dorthin, wo uns noch niemand kennt
und dort irgendwie das Leben neu
beginnen.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Wunsch,
bis dann halten wir es hier noch
aus, glaube ich.
Was für mich von den Geschichten von
Anne Wizorek, Sigi Maurer
und Jolanda Spiess-Hegglin bleibt,
ist ein Gefühl der Hoffnung.
Ich weiß, so wie wohl alle
anderen Frauen auch, ganz
genau, wie schlimm sich Sexismus
und Hass anfühlen.
Und trotzdem bringen uns diese
Erfahrungen auch näher zusammen,
wenn wir sie denn miteinander
teilen.
Das Wissen, dass wir nicht alleine
sind und dass wir gemeinsam viel
erreichen können im Kampf
um eine gerechtere Welt, macht mir
Mut.